what is your view then on the global
reaction to this variant being detected
in south africa extremely premature
and um you know it is as if they went
into a frenzy and each and everyone out
there are making a great um
about this and the question is you know
what
why
the clinical symptoms are not the same
than with delta
extreme tiredness and fatigue
under young people that was how we first
detected
with a bit of a body ache and pain and a
headache
very very similar to what you will
normally see with any viral infection
what we have seen so far is people that
has been vaccinated let's contact the
virus and it's mild very very mild
symptoms
[Music]
two weeks from now one we might see a
different picture we might see it a
total different clinical picture
from from us what we're experiencing
currently but but for now we can't even
cite it skyped the vaccine efficacy we
can't say that
[Music]
the prohibition of travel is not
informed by science
nor will it be effective in preventing
the spread of this variant the emergence
of the omicron variant should be a
wake-up call to the world that vaccine
inequality cannot be allowed to continue
until everyone is vaccinated
everyone will continue to be at risk
with very low vaccine access with the
inability to be able to fully make our
own vaccines and to be able to get out
of this pandemic fast enough in a timely
manner with the vaccine about it that we
are witnessing and the stigmatization of
certain countries in africa related to
the variant this is not a good look for
the global north what we need is
cooperation what we need is global
solidarity and what we're getting in
return is actually a very punitive
approach to how we can actually all
manage the spending
you